[Music]
you know it's funny I was so happy for
your success because you interned on our
show yeah back in the olden time yeah
did you have fun memories I did I had
the best time here it was so great
I actually I brought along some pictures
well you got photos yes I brought some
photos from when I was an intern
good to see you there's oh there I am
there's a nice young lad this is from
1958 we look sort of related I think
like we kind of look like we could be oh
and this is me at your desk yeah I know
it's not supposed to happen you've got a
lot of questions to answer no one sits
behind Bessie Lou I guess that was a
tradition for interns you get to sit
behind the desk on the last day yeah put
on a cool jean jacket and go because I
know it's funny you mentioned our
similarity you're a redhead did you find
it that drew you into comedy in any way
when you were did it help you like
because I found that when I was when I
was younger I was the only one my
parents had six kids and I was the only
one that had red hair and for some
reason that maybe gave me the idea to be
a little weirder I don't know yeah I
think I think it did for sure and then
when I started like being doing more
auditions and stuff I always would get
like sent out unlike the most sort of
like offensive like they would always
like that one of the first auditions I
did was for this peanut planters peanut
ad and they were looking for like an
extremely unattractive woman it said
that in the square I said it they
basically we can do some stuff with
makeup but there has to be a good amount
of ugly there like and the basis of the
ad was that like this woman would be
like so unattractive and all these guys
would be following her and you'd be like
why would they follow her she's like the
worse than ever and then at the end of
it you find out she was using the
peanuts as like perfume so these so the
men are folding her she smells like
peanuts yeah
that's war unless planter's is a sponsor
I'm being given the thumbs up I think
that's very funny
that's terrible also you're a very
attractive that's sir Thank you very
no I got there and I chose I got and I
did like an underbite like as I was
doing the audition I like what I was
doing an underbite and they're like what
are you doing and I was like I thought
the underbite would help me to like look
more unattractive and they were like you
can you're fine I once I never wanted to
be an actor but once when I was out here
years and years ago when I was like 22
and trying to put things together I went
to they told me they wanted me to
audition for a part and they sent a
script over to my cruddy apartment and
I'll never forget they didn't specify
which of the two characters it was and
so I was on the phone with the person
who had sent the script to me and and I
remember it saying like I don't know
which character it is and the person
said remind me what are the two
characters and I said tab his devilish
good looks make women weaken the knees
you know he's the coolest guy in town
and and you know his blazing sensuality
and the person on the phone said what's
the other one I was like chip what he
lacks in confidence he also lacks in
charm this gangly goofball you know is a
blot on humanity and the person was like
there we go and I think I got once it
was it was almost like an exploitation
film and there was a character that they
wanted me to play it the full
description was he's a fat worthless
piece of
[Applause]
and that was like what part of fat
worthless pieces major thing goody
Andy I saw that movie and you were
really good it was really good